we learned overnight that a brazen
attack on a casino in the Philippines
killed at least 37 people a heavily
armed gunman opened fire inside and set
gaming tables on fire more than 70 were
hurt and it happened at a resort in
Manila vladimir duthiers of our
streaming network cbsn is here with how
the attack unfolded glad good morning
good morning the Philippine government
has been battling Isis affiliated groups
in the south of the country for the past
two weeks but are not calling this
attack an act of terror police say those
killed were not shot but died from what
appears to be smoke inhalation from
fires the suspected gunman had set
amateur video shot on the grounds of
Resorts World Manila shows the chaos and
confusion after a lone gunmen stormed
the resort complex you can hear what
sounded like gunshots from video
captured from a neighboring building
panicked guests rushed from the resort
and some of the injured were treated on
the scene as the straw' family members
searched for their loved ones they shall
be annular we are so worried as parents
this man said we have not known where
our daughter is since midnight we have
not heard from her there are no
indications of terrorist activity all
indications point to a criminal act when
apparently emotionally disturbed
individual these pictures provided by
the Philippine national police show the
suspected gunman officials say after he
made his way through the resort shooting
TV screens and setting parts of the
casino on fire he retreated to a hotel
room we were able to shoot
and wound the gunman while hold up the
attacker doused his body in gasoline and
took his own life by setting himself on
fire we are still investigating and
trying to ascertain why somebody would
be so senseless
and have such a motive real one in
mourning with the families of those
affected by this tragedy now officials
say the suspect tried to rob the casino
attempting to steal over two million
dollars worth of chips kale it makes no
sense thank you very much lad